let's start today with a discussion
about the economy is the economy a
disaster well many on the right say that
it is now we're going to look at the
most important metrics for evaluating
how the economy is doing the reason I'm
doing this is whether you're on the left
or on the right my suggestion is don't
make this political many on the right
who say the Biden economy is a disaster
are making this political and you know
that while I have my political opinions
I don't think we should have a death
penalty I think abortion should be legal
and accessible and affordable in most
cases I believe in the decriminalization
if not legalization of many drugs you
know these These are opinions of mine
when it comes to things like gas prices
debt and deficit the economy my
preference is to take an extremely sober
empirical approach and we can always
predict the recession is coming the type
of economic system we have at least
historically has always eventually
gotten to a recession or a depression
could we enter into one tomorrow sure
will we probably get into one at some
point yeah probably but when people come
to you maybe with tears in their eyes
and then they say the Biden economy is a
disaster
I would challenge you to say to them
which underlying metric tells us that
let's look at the most important ones
GDP growth the last few quarters 3.2
percent growth 2.6 growth 1.3 percent
growth very unremarkable not
mind-blowingly explosive the way we saw
during the immediate coveted recovery
and not problematic right I mean you
zoom out and you see GDP growth has been
in this relatively tight range big
decline for covid big recovery in that
quarter after the big Decline and then
just fine GDP growth numbers so we said
is GDP indicative of an economic problem
no it is not we then go to the
unemployment rate
one of the lowest unemployment rates
we've had the chart on the screen goes
back before 1950 looks like it starts
around 1948 and we see periods where
unemployment has been down in the three
percent range a period in the early 50s
a period in the late 60s touching the
the very high threes around the year
2000 the.com boom
um and then spiking right when covet hit
and we are now down to
3.6 unemployment one of the lowest
unemployment rates in history so we say
well the picture painted by GDP and
unemployment certainly is not indicative
of an economic crisis as of today we
then look at the inflation rate but
David sir everything is so expensive
because of the Biden inflation well if
you actually look that inflationary
period started well before Biden it has
been historically higher than we saw uh
During the period starting in the mid
90s but but inflation has now declined
declined declined to just below right
around five percent
exactly where I predicted we would be
towards the end of the summer I said
somewhere between four and five percent
it seems like we will be there this is
not hugely shocking if you've been
following the trend line and you see
that while we still have higher
inflation than we've had you have to go
back to you know around 2010 we had a
little bit of a spike in inflation and
then you look at around 1990 and then
certainly in the mid 70s very high
inflation uh World War II era okay
inflation has been higher it's coming
down so now we build the picture GDP
unemployment inflation it doesn't look
like a crisis we then look at the
consumer confidence index now this is an
opinion based index admittedly and you
do see that when we were in the thick of
covid consumer confidence declined
significantly it is important it is
important to look at the y-axis here and
see that it goes from 96 to 102. this is
a relatively tight range it is
absolutely true that right before
the.com bust a consumer confidence was
very high
um and then in the midst of the
2008-2009 recession consumer confidence
was low it got very low during covid and
it is now recovered to a level that we
saw around 2012 and to a level we saw
during the recovery from 2008 and in the
early 90s so consumer confidence has
been low but it is climbing well what
about stock market performance David
let's look at that S P 500
um four percent one-year return not
amazing but certainly not a crisis year
to date 11 return from the S P 500 the
three-year is now a 10
annualized return very very healthy you
look at five year nine percent return
and ten year 10 return the stock market
is basically fine yes we see these
erratic erratic up and down days uh
sporadically that's something that's
been part of the stock market so we're
not finding any red flags well maybe
unemployment is low and GDP is okay in
consumer confidence is increasing and
the stock market is doing fine
but what about wages well we look at the
federal wage growth tracker and you see
that wage growth sustained now starting
about uh a year and a quarter ago
has been at some of the highest levels
that we've seen dating all the way back
to 1980 wage growth but these are crappy
jobs well wages are going up and you
actually see very nice wage growth so
the fine we have many jobs but they are
crap wage growth seems to be doing okay
we then look at the balance of trade and
you see that we still have a trade
deficit but after bottoming out
um a couple years ago the trade deficit
has been reduced reduced reduced it's
really important to understand if you
look at this chart you'll see that we've
had trade deficits dating all the way
back to the mid 70s we have had trade
deficits in the United States since 1976
because we have become a country
that Imports a ton of oil and consumer
products okay the trade balance is not
particularly
shocking if you understand the American
economy and then lastly well what about
interest rates yes we are seeing an
increase in interest rates this is
making mortgages more expensive this is
also making it so that you can get five
percent in a high yield savings account
which is pretty damn attractive I will
tell you what you have to understand
about interest rates and we have a chart
up on the screen where you see extremely
high interest rates in the early 80s and
then you see extremely low interest
rates almost zero from about two
thousand eight up until about 2016.
interest rates in the U.S reach their
highest level in 1981. and you can see
it on the chart because the FED raised
rates to combat soaring inflation and to
try to stabilize the economy that's the
story of high interest rates in 81.
since then we've seen interest rates
basically decline for 40 years
all the way down to essentially zero
levels in 2010 after the global
financial crisis again in 2020 they
dropped back to zero after the coveted
pandemic and now interest rates are
going back up to a level that we saw in
2006 still below what where we saw right
before 9 11 well below what we had in
the late 80s so there is really no big
dramatic story on interest rates as well
so I continue to recommend when these
economy doom and gloomers come to you
and they start telling you these stories
about the Biden economy the first thing
to say is listen the less regulated the
version of capitalism we have the more
endemic to the system booms and busts
will be
there may well be a recession or
depression coming but what current
indicator is suggestive of that now the
one I didn't mention which they might go
to is labor participation rate the
population of the country continues to
go up and so it is true that at most
times there are more people than ever
working
and more people than ever not working it
is not a particular particularly
reliable indicator of economic health
and that's why I didn't even include it
ask them for the facts show them the
receipts